okay here we go with another duel
comentarii match and what do i play on
the first move yeah don't ye five let's
see what are the Kings gambit okay okay
I'll take it ng5 supposed to be aha ya
know I can play g4 and win apiece but I
want to run play a little bit more solid
c 3 looks a bit strange here hmm maybe I
can win the peace now after all of the
g4 cannot move the night really it
shouldn't be enough all right let's play
solid maybe this will just transpose oh
no doesn't transpose okay yeah this kind
of position you roll over you can only
get any kings game it really really
weird but this whole setup is a bit
strange with Bishop d3 antum c3 maybe
it's an idea to this is possible not
sure that looks logical to get some play
in the center somewhat weakening maybe
but
came
the knight c6 may be
trying to get the square e five if you
place d5
okay let's finish development somehow
I'd see three
can i play Queen B 6 just being greedy
cannot play d5 young be too has also
hanging
yeah messy position of course as usual
but objectively I cannot believe any
others
I just want to take you for I don't see
how he could cover that and often on
Vita also exchange you nemore provides a
few castles I take you for the bishop
and we'll exchange of lots of stuff even
the Queen's
hmm
I think maybe it will be six would have
been even stronger if I would have
played this instead of not gsm okay um I
taking now on d4 let's say with the
bishop you might have not a forearm but
I can take III then no problem okay and
what sorts work n nothin I'll just take
it don't see any any problem with this
now we'll also exchange Quint I think
yeah okay cost you success some is sure
to fall but I hope this isn't a big deal
just drooped your age exchange one look
at the end term each all end game should
just win because of the porn on f3 yeah
okay i just take King do 797 hmm could
be a bit annoying but ok not see 7 is
also a threat I could what I could
castle just just simple
not sure if I want to what if I just
play
hmm 96
okay i need to play quick come down to
one minute again
you know just want to go to e5
k can
you can take on the six doesn't matter
much would even help me to get get rid
of the night okay let's exchange
somewhat more
k
this looks like an inconvenient pin well
and now okay
yeah it's not not that easy to win
at least with 20 seconds on the clock
ok this is I don't know really a lot of
extra points yeah didn't quite make it
timewise what's the Ted status low I
know what does it won't move or
something yeah I can just meet you ok
next game um what do happen yeah let's
let's go d for again
yeah some kind of benoni okay let's
let's do this let's not be a total bore
will see three or something yeah the
check is some meant to displace a piece
okay this strange piece configuration I
want to avoid Bishop g4 now
the arm this is very very weakening
let's see
yeah but I have 42 to open this
yeah well p 5s are no big issue multiple
ways to play this okay let's let's just
bury the bishop here KCM yeah let's get
rid of this one okay the bishop on g7 is
just completely dead and just winsome to
open up the position so be five it's
just a move our welcome ok now he wants
to maybe go for h5 you okay let's play
edge form
so what now I try for beyond possible
make sure that the bishop never does
anything again okay let's take this
needs to take with the deep own
otherwise g5 is falling
on d takes a 556 though it's are also
very very bad yeah maybe this was the
lesser evil even okay can take it simply
but so terribly is anyway I try to get
on the H file just maybe even stronger
to make a director check out of this
okay
I take no it can play on Butchie aid
okay I switch the the night over as well
go to h5
yeah but I can also open up the
queenside if he tries to hide them
ya think the queenside is just falling
apart now okay not to deform this may be
the last term try but I can just place
the 3m okay
okay let's say Queenie to c3 in quincy
for Roxy 8 it's no direct win but it's a
very close
then I can play be seven would be a dye
can capture I cannot capture be seven
because of Queen c6 checks out this
should be resins actually all this has
some trick don't see any
no no that's all
cannot cover c6 then should be six even
with mate
ok
yes but maybe this is the easiest want
to keep the the bishop
can bring the roof over to a one simply
yep yeah f6 and g5 was just 22 weakening
and completely killing the bishop yeah
thanks for for watching make sure to
watch both videos and both channels and
make sure to subscribe if you like the
videos it's em for free to get informed
about new videos